le vaccin spoutnik vais bientôt
fabriquer au coeur de l'union européenne
un accord signé ce mardi avec le fonds
d'investissements directs de russie va
permettre à l'italie de devenir le
premier pays de lieu à produire ce
vaccin contre le coc vide 19 une étape
clé pour ce sérum alors que son
utilisation n'a pas encore été approuvé
par l' agence européenne du médicament
nous sommes prêts à coopérer avec la
russie si spoutnik fonctionne et si la
huai mais la rfa disent qu'il est sûre
et efficace alors je me fiche de la
nationalité de ce vaccin
cette société pharmaceutique située près
de milan va ainsi produire à partir du
mois de juillet plus de 10 millions de
doses d'ici la fin de l'année
le site accueillera l'ensemble du cycle
de production
la filiale italienne du groupe suisse à
dien a annoncé que le vaccin pourra être
vendus à d'autres pays à condition
d'obtenir l'approbation réglementaire
italienne pour le président de cette
filiale
il était temps d'agir j'ai vu trop de
morts j'ai vu des camions militaires ont
mené des cercles de bergen il ya un an
avec vous envisagez produire le vaccin
dans votre usine
il y a un an je pensais que j'aimerais
faire quelque chose pour aider et aucune
occasion de ce genre ne s'était présenté
les autorités russes souhaitent
développer une vingtaine de productions
similaires en europe notamment en
allemagne ou encore en espagne le vaccin
spoutnik v a déjà été approuvée par 48
pays du monde
cet accord intervient alors que mario
draghi a annoncé que l'italie traverse
une nouvelle vague épidémique selon les
médecins le variant angles est
irresponsable de la hausse des
contaminations et des décès sur le sol
italien ces derniers jours cette semaine
la barre des 100000 morts a été dépassé
une situation critique qui a poussé le
ministère italien de la santé a décrété
un recond finement d'une grande partie
du territoire à partir de ce lundi